all right professor proton fans get
ready to meet dr. Sheldon Cooper and dr.
Amy Farrah Fowler a pair of real-life
scientists who may win the Nobel Prize
that's like the Kids Choice Award but
with more science and less slime hi
thanks for having us
Kids Choice Award why are they like kids
choose anything they're basically human
larvae well they are kind of our target
audience greetings children toys am i
right he is he has hundreds of them so
you two have discovered something that a
lot of people are really excited about
huh we have now before you explain it
keep in mind that our average viewer is
this many okay imagine you're looking in
a mirror the image you see looks just
like you
that's called symmetrical now imagine
you have a billion mirrors and each of
them reflects one thing about you
correctly and a billion things about you
incorrectly and imagine the set of
incorrect things are floating in an
abstract in dimensional hyperspace now
imagine there was never a mirror to
begin with oh is that a doorbell I
didn't hear anything
there it is again Sheldon why don't you
answer it but I don't know who it is
maybe it's a special guest who I invited
just to surprise you why don't you open
it up and find out this is a terrible
message to send to children children you
never open the door if you don't know
who's on the other side you always make
your mommy or daddy do it while you hide
under the bed and try to imagine what
your superhero name will be when you
avenge their deaths
I'll get it but it can't be the Silver
Shadow that's mine hello
[Applause]
you're William Shatner you can go they
bill who can I call you captain no
please will you call me science officer
Cooper this has got to stop
I think you know how to make it stop
flutter there's science of as a Cooper
[Music]
oh poor Shatner poor shad no I have to
eat lunch now well Sheldon's pretty
embarrassed so when he gets here we
should make fun of him a lot